the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns in a
song of ice and fire update video all
right my friends in this new video let's
revisit a subject i discussed in one of
my older videos
when everyone from house of the dragon
recently sat down with entertainment
weekly they revealed some new
information that i think most of you
will find interesting i know i certainly
did because what i found out is so much
worse than we all initially thought
now as you all know when game of thrones
was entering its final season a little
over 3 years ago hbo decided they did
not want to leave westeros forever it's
no secret that game of thrones is still
the most successful show in television
history not only because of how many
fans they had but also because of the
amount of money this series was able to
make hbo there are some estimations that
say game of thrones made them billions
of dollars so you can certainly
understand why hbo would want to make
sure a game of thrones series stayed on
our televisions before the main series
game of thrones even ended they started
writing several new shows according to a
recent article hbo did some research on
george rr martin's a song of ice and
fire saga afterwards they said they had
about 15 different ideas for shows but
only five of those actually moved
forward to get turned into actual
scripts now before house of the dragon
was given the green light there was
another show that hbo was focusing on
the most this was a series about the
long night when the white walkers
originally invaded westeros roughly a
thousand years ago
one of the
hbo shows in development can you tell us
about any of those by the way blood moon
is wrapped something hasn't i i can't
go on
there's probably an hbo agent in the
in the auditorium even now um
i can say as i have said before we we
started out with a number of different
ideas all of them prequels
um
one show
which i've been calling the long night
let hbo keep saying it's not titled yet
so the show that's not called the long
night
yet
has
just finished uh filming up in belfast
and is now and and other places not just
belfast italy as well
and uh jane goldman is the writer and
the showrunner on that uh
you you've probably been familiar with
her work she uh was the scriptwriter on
several of the uh x-men movies she did
kick ass
and she did the um the kingsman both
kingsman
uh things she she scripted neil gaiman's
uh stardust so she's a very experienced
screenwriter
and she's done this story and it is set
you know 5000 years
in the past of westeros so way
way way before the events of game of
thrones and that that's the one that is
uh furthest along at the moment and it's
in pre-production and
right now it's just a pilot but it's got
the
naomi watts in it starring it's got
miranda richardson a lot of other very
uh exciting actors and uh
we'll probably be finding out in the
next couple months whether hbo is
actually going to order a full
the full series of that that is right
and meanwhile we have two other pilots
that are also in
active development at some stage and
hopefully uh in the near future one or
both of them will be uh greenlit now if
i'm being honest as anxious as i am to
see house of the dragon i was actually
even more excited for this show about
the long night this show wasn't only
going to focus on the white walkers
obviously it was also going to have a
very large focus on the starks of legend
i was hoping we would learn more about
all the fascinating secrets and
mysteries of the north i still want to
know if the night king was an ancient
member from the stark's house i also
want to know more about winterfell and
the wall and how they were constructed i
wanted to learn more about the 13th lore
commander of the night's watch and even
the children of the forest who were
living out beyond the wall there are so
many interesting things this show about
the long night could have developed
unfortunately as i'm sure most of you
already know this show never got off the
ground
they did however film one episode of the
series a very very expensive episode i
might add ever since house of the
dragons sat down with entertainment
weekly to discuss the release of their
new show they revealed a lot more
information about the show that was
ultimately shut down the one episode
they filmed for blood moon the series
about the long night they more or less
said it was so bad they won't even let
george r martin see it it's obviously so
much worse than the infamous original
pilot episode for game of thrones now if
any of you remember that story game of
thrones was nearly shut down itself
before it ever got off the ground after
dan and dave had game of thrones first
episode film for roughly 10 million
dollars they let some of their friends
watch it so they could let them know how
well they had done well it was so awful
they basically had to start all over now
thankfully they did get it right after
that because game of thrones went on to
become one of the most successful shows
ever well the series about the long
night never stood a chance not only was
this single episode three times the
amount of money but it was so disastrous
they don't even want the author watching
it the headline reads the show that
never was the recent article states one
year before game of thrones was set to
air at series finale hbo announced a
pilot order for a new successor series a
show with the working name of blood moon
it would be set thousands of years
before the events in game of thrones
during the fabled age of heroes in the
wintry apocalypse known as the long
night its showrunner jane goldman had
considerable access making acclaimed
r-rated genre hits with credits like
kick-ass and the kingsman according to
orsi who is one of the heads for drama
at hbo said bloodmoon won the bake-off
on merit blood moon really stood out as
different with unique world building
orsi says it felt very adult
sophisticated and intelligent and there
was a thematic conversation at the
center of it about disenfranchisement in
the face of colonialism and religious
extremism there was however only one
major issue
george rr martin had only written about
eight sentences about this time period
for the show leaving goldman little to
build from blood moon was a very
difficult assignment george rr martin
said there were no dragons yet and a lot
of the episode we shot revolved around a
wedding of a southern house to a
northern house and it got into the whole
history of the white walkers george r
martin made his worries obvious to hbo
and one insider admits having a show
that's nearly all invention that also
had george scratching his head at
various moments was troubling at times
they did assemble a cast headed by naomi
watts there were massive new sets built
and then bloodmoon's very first episode
was shot for a whopping 30 to 35 million
dollars and the result was locked away
in a dungeon so deep that even george r
martin has never been allowed to see it
there wasn't anything glaringly wrong
with it it wasn't unwatchable or
horrible or anything like that it was
very well made and it even looked
extraordinary now you see i just don't
believe them when they say something
like this
if it isn't unwatchable then why isn't
george rr martin who is the author who
is the damn creator not allowed to see
it
something must have gone very wrong
after wasting roughly 35 million dollars
i now understand why they were so
anxious to get house of the dragon
moving forward
thankfully that did not stop them from
making another show because it looks
like they invested even more money into
house of the dragon everything does look
amazing based on what i've seen so far
from all the different official videos
and photos i would like to think that
one day they will learn from their
mistakes i guess all of us are about to
find out soon enough when house of the
dragon releases in about 18 days from
now
[Music]
[Music]
you